voilà c'est fait c'était ma petite route
sénat très simple et très riche faune
beatles bac prend soin de son apparence
pour lui le maquillage est essentiel
c'est vraiment juste pour me sentir bien
chez les hommes on parle de gros même
pour désigner la taille d'une barbe ou
pour dessiner un sourcil pour les cils
le terme hans kara et l'expression
consacrée que les hommes puissent
s'approprier le maquillage puis un petit
peu dire écoutez c'est pas juste pour
les femmes c'est pas jeu ça ne mettons
les hommes homosexuels qui se maquillent
cette tendance n'est pas nouvelle
on avait déjà une première vague est
apparu avec les métrosexuels et qui
revient donc en force
actuellement avec 1.0 phénomène 2.0 2.0
pour une génération connectée et qui
préfèrent acheter en ligne plus commode
et surtout anonyme
chanel vient de lancer boy une gamme de
maquillage pour homme et à toronto
une marque américaine est distribué sur
le marché canadien au prince entre son
représentant parle d'une micro niches
qui se porte très bien avec un marché
qui a augmenté de 20% entre 2017 et 2018
dans cette pharmacie à montréal la
clientèle masculine ne parle pas
ouvertement de maquillage le fond de
teint il sera pas forcément demandé
comme sage en jeu mongeau je voudrais un
fond de teint mais ça va vraiment être
la demande dans le sens où le client
allait voir en dix ans
imagine imperfections j'aimerais ça
camoufler sa housse est pas
nécessairement là le total look au real
est tout simplement encore ils ont le
teint mais on voit finalement cette
espèce de cul de la jeunesse
on peut paraître à son meilleur les
québécois sont très curieux méiose - ses
causes et à un coût rec dépenses à peu
près 400 dollars par mois en produits de
maquillage ici à ce mitraillage radio
canada montréal